[Music]
in competitive counter-strike all eyes
are on one team
[Music]
[Applause]
at a time when even the best csgo teams
are struggling to remain consistent this
group of Danish destroyers has secured
an astonishing ten first-place trophies
this past year a strong us have proven
time and time again that beyond the
shadow of a doubt they are the best csgo
roster in the world right now and if
they win the upcoming kind of beats a
major they could be the greatest of all
time up until last spring a straw were
known for their inconsistency despite
winning their first major in January
2017
Astral's were mostly known for choking
in the semi-finals of nearly every
tournament they attended even once in
which they were the favorites it didn't
help that their star player device spent
the latter half of the year suffering
from a hiatal hernia on top of that
after nearly a year of middling results
ER be one of the players instrumental in
their major win decided to abandon the
roster altogether and just like it was
crazy and I was like when I got the news
one understand I was still on vacation I
was obviously shocked I didn't know what
to say right I feel still feel like
we're good friends but in all honesty I
we would just have appreciated a
conversation about it because also still
at the moment we really don't know why
he left a straw rotten majus a Danish
right for who had struggled to find
success on his previous teams and yet a
straw was decided that this relatively
unknown rife work was exactly who they
need it to become the best one of the
goals we had when we thought of
astrology 2.0 or whatever you want to
call it when we brought in megistus that
we wanted to we wanted to we want to
have an error like we wanted that we
wanted people to like analysts and other
players and like to recognize recognize
us for our style and creating the game
like creating the maeda and so for that
I think we've achieved that now at least
at some point within two months of
acquiring magic the Danes made it to the
grand finals of Dreamhack Marseille
there they pulled off a clutch against
that initiated the so-called era of
astrology they have enough time to
rotate through the Smokies trying to
find a way to kill simple who simply
will the fool and I plan to be pushing
this to kill pests rodents are
victorious
my my as flawless abstinence a
convincing fashion the grand final in
the ten months since Marseille astrology
come unstoppable they went on to win
three premier tournaments before
entering the London major as the clear
favorites after a few hiccups in the
group stage they rolled through the
playoff toppling phase liquid and
finally Navi not only did they earn
themselves a second major title they did
it without losing a single map in the
playoff stage simple the second one they
have to keep going they've got a charge
forward it misses the job flaming out
with the five Stephanie's basic the pair
of short bees read touching the bomb
part again - Pete holding it now and
there is it
the Islamist era is absolutely cemented
that is sold
above everybody else since London
astrology have won five of their last
six tournaments in December they also
became the first team to claim the Intel
grand slam and the $1,000,000 prize that
comes with it two kills away make it one
and looks like it's a done deal
nitro has no turn up in this final map
an astrologer so close to this point
what you'll get a secure that's it
season eight as well Matthew can you
believe it the first map it looked like
they were out of it it weren't turning
up their key plants were there but they
adapt it and that's why they considered
the world's best right now to be honest
every absolutely can anticipation was
the pitch was always there as they were
the heavy favorite coming in and they
show off why back-to-back easiest
back-to-back pro-league Mart side
season seven Chicago we've also trans
Team Liquid the old early lineup that's
managed to consistently match up against
them in five of their last six grand
finals bouts and are currently in the
middle of a thirty-two game win streak
on one of counterstrikes most
notoriously difficult max nuke it's
probably the most difficult yet
technically speaking and on the CT side
it's in CT said they request the most
communication because you constantly
have to move players around I think it
because it takes a huge depth of
knowledge to play the map because
there's so many rotations constantly on
going all the time when when people get
picked off so I think that's why it
seems like a starless to go out the best
team right now are so good on it the
things that a lot of straws to go
undefeated on a map as convoluted as
nuke is the same thing that makes them
so incredible at everything else they
have excellent communication impeccable
decision making and the ability to play
the odds and to do so as a unit that
they play in a way that's really smart
way to play where they take calculated
risks they pick their fights they're
very dynamic very proactive team you
know they're not going to sit back and
let you do whatever you want they're
going to try and figure out where your
weak spot on the map is and they're
going to try to take that from you when
you're trying to take one area of the
map another thing that set the straw us
apart is their organizational
infrastructure they're one of the first
CS teams to help their players with
nutrition physical fitness and mental
health if you look at this trollies
organization I think we have the whole
refreshed team behind us they're helping
us love to have doctors we have
scientists we have physical trainers
have mental trainers it's not like
they're full-time but they are available
all the time we can call them whenever
we want if we have some problems
I think what's special about drugs is
that everyone the team has
mission the same goal and also that the
supportive we found from refresh
entertainment bringing in like
professional sports people from other
other parts of sports and showing that
studies prove that if you actually are
fit and you even somewhat healthier you
will actually gain more percent that you
try to get maybe two percent performance
by by eating he'll appear in two percent
performance by working out two percent
from sleeping well all that stuff I we
try to add as many percentage as we can
and just add it together and I think
that's why we're just better than
everyone else it's been a long time
since any team has held competitive
counter-strike in such a stranglehold
and it could be the biggest gap between
first and second that we've ever seen
the strongest have put themselves in
competition with 2015 fnatic and the LG
SK roster for the title of the greatest
lineup in the history of csgo
one of the most heated discussions in
the csgo community right now is whether
Astral's are already the greatest and
why I think Australis are playing the
best counter-strike that has been played
ever since csgo came out they play in a
way where they are playing kind that the
percentages they're giving themselves
the most chances to win the game of
course the results of the kind of eats a
major will pretty much end this
conversation if a straw win the
tournament they'll simply be the
greatest of all time so come cut a visa
it'll be up to a straw Louis to make
history and up to everyone else
[Music]
they are counter-strike two levels we've
never seen before
consistency prevailed here in London
this is the team to beat to be called
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button